Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Myriam Cabon :
Si l’aventure consiste à se confronter
à l’inconnu, nous pouvons dire :
« Nous sommes des aventuriers. »
En réalité, on est des aventuriers
pour deux raisons.
On a une aventure qu’on a subie
et une aventure qu’on a choisie.
Pierre et moi,
on se rencontre le 13 juin 2015.
On a 25 ans et on est
au mariage d’un ami commun.
On a fait pendant 5 ans
la même école sans nous croiser,
mais ce soir-là, presque par hasard,
on se retrouve assis à côté.
On discute, on s’entend bien,
et une chose en entraînant une autre,
on tombe amoureux.
On découvre rapidement
qu’on a une passion commune.
Cette passion, c’est le voyage.
Ce qui est top, c’est qu’on a vraiment
la même manière de vivre le voyage.
Ce qu’on aime, c’est la nature,
les grands espaces, les rencontres.
Donc, on commence à voyager
tous les deux, en France, puis en Europe.
On a 25 ans et on en profite.
Sauf que le 13 novembre 2015,
Pierre se rend à un concert au Bataclan.
De la manière la plus inconcevable qui
soit pour nous qui avons grandi en France,
il est blessé par balle au niveau
de la colonne vertébrale.
Ce jour-là, notre vie bascule
une première fois
puisque Pierre se retrouve
en fauteuil roulant.
Pierre Cabon : Une vie complètement
nouvelle commence.
Le monde du handicap, on n'y connaît rien.
Il faut tout réapprendre : les gestes
du quotidien, les déplacements.
C’est vertigineux.
Avec ces contraintes,
on se dit qu’on ne pourra plus
faire plein de choses,
qu’on va renoncer
à tout un pan de notre vie,
dont une partie de nos voyages.
Et ça, c'est extrêmement dur.
C’est dur, mais on essaie, on apprend.
On repart en voyage,
d’abord en Europe, puis au Canada.
On patauge, on voit comment ça se passe,
toujours avec l’idée
qu’on peut faire moins de choses,
que si on veut de l’accessible, on va
se contenter de visiter des villes,
des endroits bien carrés, bien loin
de ce qu’on aime vraiment, finalement.
À chaque fois qu’on sort
des sentiers battus,
on ne voit quasiment personne en fauteuil,
ça doit bien être impossible, finalement.
On continue à voyager,
mais on ne vibre plus vraiment.
On visite, on découvre, mais
on ne vibre plus autant qu’avant.
MC : Ce plafond de verre,
on le subit longtemps.
En réalité, on va le subir
jusqu’au 4 juin 2018,
où notre vie va basculer
une deuxième fois.
Ce jour-là, on est en voyage de noces
et on décide de survoler le Grand Canyon.
On monte dans cet hélicoptère
et à quelques mètres en dessous, cette
immense forêt défile à toute vitesse.
On voit la falaise se rapprocher au loin.
On a la tête collée à la vitre, la musique
dans les oreilles, les yeux rivés dehors.
Tout à coup, en une fraction de seconde,
on se retrouve à 1500 mètres
au-dessus du sol,
après avoir passé cette fameuse falaise.
À ce moment-là, on a littéralement
le souffle coupé
et on est débordés par un sentiment
de liberté incomparable.
Cette émotion,
on se rend assez vite compte
qu’on avait fait une croix dessus
sans vraiment le réaliser.
On pensait vraiment qu’on ne pourrait plus
jamais vivre une émotion aussi intense.
C’est à ce moment précisément
qu’on décide de créer Wheeled World.
PC : À cet endroit-là,
le plafond de verre qu’on s’est
inconsciemment construit depuis 3 ans
vole complètement en éclats.
On prend conscience qu’on peut tout faire,
c’est juste une question d’organisation.
Les premières limites aux voyages
en fauteuil sont celles que l’on s’impose.
À partir de là,
on ne veut plus qu’une chose :
faire en sorte que
l’impossible n’existe plus.
On ne veut plus l’entendre ce mot
que ce soit dans la bouche d’une personne
valide ou celle d’un handicapé.
On veut combattre les limites, qu’elles
soient physiques ou psychologiques,
qui, un jour, nous ont fait croire qu’on
ne pouvait plus, qu’on ne pourrait plus.
MC : Pour combattre ces limites, on décide
de créer le media de l’aventure pour tous,
qui a deux ambitions.
La première, c'est de donner envie de
voyager, donc de rouvrir des perspectives.
La 2e, c’est de permettre
à chacun de le faire sereinement,
qu’il soit valide
ou en situation de handicap.
Pour que ce media soit utile,
on va couvrir un maximum de destinations.
On se lance
dans un premier projet d’envergure :
un tour du monde de 14 mois pendant lequel
on traversera 4 continents et 15 pays.
Pour que ce media soit utile, il faut
qu’il attire un maximum de personnes.
Donc, on va essayer
de marquer les esprits :
on se lance un défi majeur par continent.
On va commencer par le Machu Picchu
avec ses centaines de marches.
Ensuite on part pour la Nouvelle-Zélande,
qu’on traversera en tandem pour mettre
du piment dans l’aventure,
avant ensuite de s’envoler
vers le Kilimandjaro,
et d’assister aux Jeux paralympiques
à Tokyo en 2020.
PC : Mais ce tour du monde est interrompu
par la pandémie au bout de 7 mois
au lieu des 14 prévus.
Mais ça a été sept mois
d’une intensité exceptionnelle.
On a redécouvert la vie.
On a vibré à nouveau en kayak au pied d’un
glacier, à cheval dans des déserts arides,
et à vélo dans des paysages sauvages.
On a eu la chance d’avoir un parcours
de reconstruction extraordinaire,
d’être entourés,
de rebondir pleinement jusqu’à vivre
de notre passion, le voyage et l’aventure.
Mais ce n'est pas donné à tous.
Face à ce monde inconnu
qu’est le handicap,
vivre avec ce nouveau paramètre peut
se révéler un vrai parcours du combattant,
tant sur le plan physique
que sur le plan psychologique.
En fonction du contexte de chacun,
de son environnement,
de sa personnalité,
de ses souffrances parfois,
on peut être amené à perdre ce combat
et à subir sa différence au quotidien.
MC : En France, 12 millions de personnes
sont en situation de handicap.
Douze millions, c’est presque
un Français sur cinq.
Parmi ces 12 millions, 850 000 personnes
sont à mobilité réduite,
et chaque année,
1 500 nouveaux blessés médullaires
se retrouvent dans cette situation.
De tous les âges, de toutes
les catégories sociales.
Ce chiffre nous apprend quelque part
que le handicap touche
énormément de personnes
et qu’il ne fait pas
de différence entre nous.
La question qu’on avait envie de
vous poser aujourd’hui, de se poser,
quand on regarde ce chiffre,
c’est : comment faire que le handicap
ne soit plus un frein ?
De toutes ces aventures,
de tous ces voyages,
ce qu’on retire, nous,
c’est que pour que le handicap ne soit
plus un frein, il faut deux choses.
On va avoir besoin de nous
et on va avoir besoin des autres.
PC : On a besoin de nous
car nous sommes les premiers
à avoir les clés pour tirer le meilleur
d’une situation qu’on n’a pas choisie.
Pour atteindre nos objectifs, pour
renouer avec ce qui nous anime vraiment
et trouver le bonheur auquel on aspire,
il nous faut faire preuve
de détermination d’abord.
Combattre les barrières psychologiques
qui nous empêchent d’essayer
selon le principe que ce n’est pas
possible, que c’est trop compliqué.
Il nous faut oser
nous lancer dans l’inconnu
pour dépasser les idées reçues
qui nous enchaînent.
Il nous faut faire
preuve de créativité ensuite.
Se concentrer sur les contraintes
que nous pouvons influencer
tout en acceptant celles
qui sont immuables
pour s’attacher à chercher
des solutions de contournement :
développer une technique
pour monter un escalier,
créer un équipement
pour parcourir les déserts
ou trouver un moyen de transport adapté
pour se déplacer sur les routes.
Et enfin, il nous faut faire preuve
de résilience et d’humilité
parce que malgré tous nos efforts,
il nous faudra savoir accepter nos échecs,
les digérer, même si c’est difficile,
pour apprendre
et créer les conditions qui nous
permettront de trouver une nouvelle voie.
Cela demande une énergie monumentale.
Si nous sommes allés chercher les
difficultés à l’autre bout du monde,
sachez que le quotidien
d’une personne handicapée
peut vite être rempli
de petits et grands obstacles
tout aussi insurmontables
qu’un sommet rocailleux,
surtout quand ils sont subis et non
choisis, et surtout s’ils sont récurrents.
Quand une difficulté nous dépasse,
quand on est à court d’énergie
ou qu’on est simplement fatigué,
on a besoin des autres.
MC : On a besoin des autres
pour une raison évidente, je pense.
A plusieurs, tout devient possible
parce qu’on va de manière
beaucoup plus simple
réussir à dépasser les obstacles physiques
qui nous entravent au quotidien.
Pour l’anecdote, au mois de janvier,
on a eu la chance de partir en Martinique.
A l’est de la Martinique,
il y a une presqu’île,
la presqu’île de la Caravelle,
sur laquelle il y a un panorama absolument
sublime, un point de vue magique.
Mais il faut monter un peu.
On se lance dans la randonnée.
Le chemin est relativement plat.
Plus ça va, plus les pentes sont
raides et difficiles à grimper pour nous.
Il fait 35 degrés, c’est extrêmement dur,
mais on ne lâche rien,
parce qu’on veut vraiment voir ce fameux
point de vue qui nous a été promis.
On continue.
Au moment où on arrive au sommet -
on a fait 90 % du boulot a priori -
on est coincé entre les arbres.
On n’y voit absolument rien.
Il n’y a aucune vue.
Pour accéder à cette fameuse vue,
il faut réussir à monter jusqu’au phare.
Et pour monter jusqu’au phare,
il faut passer quatre escaliers
avec des marches irrégulières, en pierre,
des rochers absolument partout.
En somme, quelque chose
d’impossible pour nous,
parce que c’est beaucoup trop dangereux de
s’y lancer si on n’est que tous les deux.
Vous imaginez notre déception.
Sauf qu’au moment
où on contemple ces escaliers,
quatre inconnus se dirigent vers nous.
On discute,
ils attrapent le fauteuil de Pierre
et ils le font monter jusqu’au phare.
C’est dur - il fait chaud,
on est en plein soleil.
Pierre est quand même assez lourd.
Mais du coup, ils vont jusqu’au bout.
Ils donnent l’effort qu’il faut
et ils ne nous laissent pas là.
Vous me direz, ces personnes
qu’on ne connaissait pas,
elles nous ont aidés sur 10 % du chemin.
10 %, ce n’est pas grand-chose.
En réalité, ils ont
fait beaucoup plus que ça.
Ils nous ont offert l’opportunité
d’aller au bout d’une aventure,
de vivre une expérience
extraordinaire jusqu’au bout,
en ayant fourni des efforts
avant de notre côté
et en les partageant
avec des personnes pour la suite.
Et ça, c’est incroyable.
Ça, c’est pour le soutien physique -
on a toujours besoin des autres.
Mais on a besoin des autres aussi
parce que c’est la perception des autres
qui va nous aider à faire tomber
les barrières, psychologiques cette fois,
qui se dressent devant nous
quand on est en fauteuil.
On est tous quelque part influencés
par notre environnement :
la culture dans laquelle on a grandi,
les convictions de nos proches,
le regard des autres.
Pour que le handicap
ne soit plus un frein,
la première étape,
c’est déjà que la société ne nous
fasse pas sentir qu’il en est un.
Une différence,
c’est juste une différence en fait.
Ce n’est ni mieux ni moins bien, pas
besoin d’appliquer un jugement de valeur.
D'ailleurs, on a tous nos contraintes.
Il y a des grands, des petits,
il y en a qui ont des lunettes,
Il y en a qui sont mauvais
en maths, ça arrive souvent.
Certains ont une condition
physique très développée,
d’autres ont beaucoup de moyens
ou un petit peu moins.
Et personne ne vient nous juger
sur ces différences-là
qui font notre individualité.
Pourquoi est-ce que
le handicap serait différent ?
Notre conviction,
c’est que si on essaie
de comprendre les contraintes de l’autre
et qu’on les intègre
dans sa manière d’agir
sans y apposer de jugement,
sans préjuger
des capacités de la personne,
on peut dissoudre le handicap.
On apprend à aider
de manière utile, sans intrusion,
et ce faisant, on arrive à rendre plus
accessible le quotidien des autres,
quelles que soient leurs contraintes.
Finalement, ce qu’on fait
quand on essaye de comprendre,
c’est qu’on libère ces personnes
qui sont porteuses d’une différence.
On les libère parce qu’on les autorise
à porter toute leur énergie,
qu’elle soit physique ou mentale,
sur d’autres préoccupations
que les problématiques du quotidien.
Et c’est pour ça, surtout,
qu’on a besoin des autres.
PC : Si on a besoin de nous et des autres,
pour faire tomber ces barrières
psychologiques et physiques,
notre conclusion, c’est que le handicap
est une aventure collective.
C’est en construisant ensemble
qu’on fera en sorte
qu’il ne soit plus un frein pour personne.
En essayant de comprendre l’autre,
en faisant preuve d’empathie,
en agissant chacun à notre échelle,
on peut rendre leur liberté
à toutes ces personnes qui, comme nous,
un jour, ont été confrontées
à cette différence, à ces freins.
S’il y a entraide et esprit d’équipe,
il n’y a plus vraiment de handicap.